hello everybody very good morning to you
it is seven o'clock you're very welcome
to join us on the breakfast show here on
sky news it began late last night
russia's new offensive in eastern
ukraine that's been called the battle
for donbass reports coming in overnight
of several areas targeted along the
front line we'll take you through it and
also get reaction from ukrainian voices
too the other big story today of course
a prime minister preparing to face down
his mps over partygate by making a
statement in the comments but with more
fines possibly heading his way and
several tory mps saying that he should
go now will it draw a line under party
gate we'll get the view of the northern
ireland secretary brandon lewis in just
a moment and also the shadow attorney
general emily thornbury class will speak
to one of those senior conservatives who
think he should go at uh that's at
hufflepuff state we'll find out more
then it's tuesday the 19th of april
[Music]
the battle for don bass ukraine says
russia has begun a major new offensive
in the east
misery of mario paul how the last
remaining residents of the bassish city
spend their days with claims russia is
using bunker buster bombs
partygate pressure the prime minister
prepares to update parliament on those
downing street allegations as the number
of tories calling for him to go grows
i'm in dover where more boats of asylum
seekers arrived over the sunny bank
holiday weekend and it looks like
pressure and backlash over the policy to
send them to rwanda look set to increase
the greatest pain any parents can feel
manchester united footballer cristiano
ronaldo says he and his partner are
devastated as they announce the death of
one of their newborn twins
the great rail sale why plans to sell
thousands of train tickets for less to
boost travel post covet are in the
firing line
depp v herd we bring you the latest
revelations from court including photos
of apparent injuries with johnny depp
expected to give evidence later on today
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world a snapshot of
homelessness in modern britain to mark
this new exhibition we'll speak to a
woman who used to live on the streets
who turned her life around and that's
just after half past nine
yes bamra
oh want something more
[Music]
and have we got what it takes to bend it
like beckham 20 years on from the hit
movie we'll ask a football coach yasmin
hussein what it meant for helping to
boost women's football in the uk
[Music]
morning everyone we start with the
breaking news you're waking up to that
russia has begun its new offensive in
eastern ukraine reports coming into us
overnight of a push by russian military
across much of the front line that
stretches some 300 miles across the
donbass region
this the new tactic after president
putin failed in his bid to take kiev the
head of ukraine's national security
council saying their military is for now
holding out
so the ukraine military's general staff
says that vladimir putin's forces have
increased assaults in the luhansk and
donetsk regions in the donbass as well
as in the area close by meanwhile
ukrainian military officials said street
battles have begun in crimea and that
evacuation is impossible
in the southern port city of marriott
commander of the ukrainian national
guard that was holding out against
russian forces said in a video message
that russia had begun dropping
bunker-busting bombs on the azers-style
steel plant where the regiment is taking
cover
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
announced the attack in his nightly
address to the nation
now we can state that russian troops
have begun the battle for the donbass
which they have been preparing for a
long time a significant part of the
entire russian army is now concentrated
on this offensive
no matter how many russian troops are
driven there we will fight we'll defend
ourselves and we'll do it every day
we won't give up anything ukrainian
deborah standing by for us in kiev again
this morning hello to you deborah it had
uh been talked about for some time it
looks as though the russians are moving
in to the east of the country now
yes this is a second and potentially
decisive phase of the war we're almost a
full eight weeks into the invasion
russian forces gave up effectively on
their initial attempt to take the
capital they pulled their forces out of
the north of the country and regrouped
them in the east the east has been a
scene of war as well from the beginning
but now the new russian tactic having
failed to break ukraine's defenses in a
simultaneous fashion across the whole of
the country is to concentrate its
superior firepower on the east this
could well be the biggest test yet for
ukraine's armed forces and both sides
need to win russia suffered a defeat
here in kiev and it needs to win in the
east ukraine of course needs to keep its
territory
thanks very much secretary of state for
northern ireland brandon lewis is with
us this morning
can we start with ukraine please
minister thank you for joining us on the
program this morning what's the latest
situation as we understand it in the
donbass region well as you've just
reported actually we've all seen the
reports overnight with russia's uh
moving on that eastern side
and we will continue to do as we said
all the way through to do everything we
can to support ukraine in in what is a a
ferocious battle with a uh an invasion
putin is taking for that is becoming
more more about poland by the day if
that's possible what are we going to do
about these two british fighters that
have been taken hostage well it's
dreadful to see anybody being taken
hostage obviously british forces that's
something the government is always very
focused on the prime minister is
continually in contact with colleagues
and partners around the world both
through nato and obviously directly with
president zelinski will continue to do
everything we can to support uh anybody
um
from the uk and anybody actually as we
have done with the ukrainian people in
the work that they're doing to defend
their country in a democratic country
but how much sympathy should we have for
them i remember um the defense secretary
saying at the time that he really didn't
appreciate uh i think it was him or in
fact the armed forces minister saying
you know people going out there just so
they can get selfies to come back how
much sympathy should we have for people
that go when they were told they
shouldn't well we're very look what one
of these is very clear is this is a very
dangerous situation the armed forces
both ukrainian armed forces and the uk
armed forces have their own processes
and procedures people should be
following the law so we should be we are
there to support ukraine we are doing
that in a very practical way as northern
ireland secretary i've been very
fortunate to see some of the work being
done in northern ireland producing the
end laws for example which are being
sent out to ukraine that's what we're
doing as a country and that's the right
way it should be people who want to
support ukraine what we would encourage
people to do is to do it through the
right channels putting that financial
support in as hundreds of thousands of
people in uk are doing it rather than
rather than taking very dangerous and
actually not legal processes to go out
and act in that way but having said that
obviously we want to see everybody in
ukraine being safe of whatever their
nationality and that's why it's
important that russia and putin's regime
pull out of this invasion but are we
involved in trying to get them back to
the uk well i appreciate you you
appreciate i'm not going to comment on
what are effectively national security
issues what we're saying to people is
you should not be traveling out to
ukraine
because i'm not going to comment on
armed forces processes and i'm not going
to they're not armed forces are they
well we are in an armed conflict in
ukraine and it is right that we continue
to be very clear of people well
ukraine is an armed conflict republican
i'm sure the president of ukraine would
say is an armed conflict we are
supporting that we're doing that through
the proper process
do we still have a responsibility to
bring them back home well we always have
responsibility for british citizens
which we take seriously we've got to get
the balance right with ukraine that's
why i say to anybody do not travel
illegally to ukraine the armed forces in
ukraine have the support of the uk we're
continuing to put that support in and
that's the right way to do it people who
want to help in ukraine there are ways
to do that both financially and people
who open up their homes that is not the
way i understand what russia's saying is
if you give us victor medvedek then you
can have these two brits back is that
something that we would get involved
with that sort of negotiation this is an
oligarch who um as we know was an
opposition leader in ukraine for a while
mp there i think at the moment well
we're actually going through the process
of sanctioning people are close to putin
regime we're not going to be
looking at how we can help russia we're
looking to actually ensure that the
pewter regime is unsuccessful in this
abhorrent invasion and we'll continue to
do everything we can to support the
ukrainian people the ukrainian president
and government to defeat beauty i
understand so these guys are on there
and then really for now well they
shouldn't have been there it's an
illegal act to be there obviously
anybody will have sympathy with somebody
who has been taken hostage but we have
got to make sure that we follow the
proper processes that we are dealing
with this in the right way we give the
support in the right way that the
ukrainian armed forces and ukrainian
government ukrainian people can make
good use of that is what those official
processes are about that's what hundreds
of thousands of people here in the uk
are doing and we should be very proud of
that and grateful for the people of the
uk who are doing it let's talk about the
fact that it's a thousand days today
since boris johnson became prime
minister there was an opinion poll
yesterday jl partners
um saying the words that were
been in water before we go with this one
things like that the way they described
him was liar that was the most common
word used right in the middle of this
bubble here
followed by incompetent and
untrustworthy
it's not a great look is it buffoon in
there as well
well i work with the prime minister on a
range of issues across the uk and
obviously particularly for northern
ireland and i've been working with
someone whose focus has always been on
delivering for people it's been through
covered um all the way through code
again is reality isn't it and this is
what people think of him well this is
why the problem i've got to say the
prime minister himself has been very
clear in the statement he made last week
he's apologized for what's happened he
said he would make changes at number 10
which he has been making we've seen some
substantial changes there and he's
focused but you know the key people
well he's been he's already changed the
chief of staff and some of the key
people around the team in number 10
which he said he would do
he is very much focused on the issues
that are affecting people whether it's
around the cost of living whether it's
around continuing the work as we come
out of it and supporting obviously the
people of youth but he did say that he
hadn't broken the rules
but he paid a fine
so he must have realized that he'd broke
the rules in order to pay the fine no
why didn't he contest it as he said in
his statement last week the prime
minister's not because he's a liar is it
no
as he said last week in his statement
and promised we'll be talking to
parliament later today so we'll make a
statement but every point he has been
clear with what he believes to be the
truth what he's also accepting is the
police have looked into this particular
issue they've taken the view that fire
should be issued he whether he accepts
that he has paid that fine um he's
apologized for that does he accept that
he broke the rules
well he's accepted that the police have
said that the rules were broken
therefore does he accept that he broke
that is very different it is very
different i'm asking you to clarify it
but the point he made to parliament was
that when he spoke to parliament he was
speaking what he believed to be the
truth and what he outlined to be the
truth that is absolutely right and
proper but does he have that i broke the
rules as he said last week he absolutely
accepts the police have found that the
rules were broken to point that they
issued a fight but it is because that's
why he's paid the fine and he has
outlined that he accepts that no does he
accept that he broke the rules
well in the sense he's paid a fine that
the police have decided it's issued
because the rules were broken but that
doesn't mean that anything he said to
parliament was inaccurate at the time
why not because what he said to
parliament he believed to be true at the
time on the first of december he said uh
all guidance was followed completely in
number 10 on the 8th of december he said
no party and no covet drills were broken
yeah and he believed that to be
absolutely true what did you think was
happening when there was cake and people
singing happy birthday and drinking beer
what do you think it was as the prime
minister himself was outlined and he did
in his statement last week that he was
at work all day he was at work when
people then
came in and wished him happy birthday in
the same way that kirsten was at work
when he was pictured having pizza and
beer with his staff but the promise i
take up with labour later on and
they will be as robustly defending their
leaders as you are
defending the prime minister but of
course it's not just one incident
let me just finish that's why the prime
minister was very clear apartment he did
not believe at that point that anything
he'd done was against the walls but he
absolutely accepts the police have
looked to this they've taken a different
view they've issued a fine he's
apologized he's paid the fine and he has
been very clear about that yet two weeks
before it's uh suggested in uh this
weekend's papers that he was organizing
the event for lee kane he's head of
comms to leave
so was that a party or not well i have
to we haven't seen that part of the
investigation here we've got to let the
police do their work get to the bottom
let me put it this way then i can only
really comment on what has been decided
yeah so he's broken the law on on one
occasion we know at the moment can a
lawmaker ever be
a law breaker
yeah i think look we do see consistently
whether it's through uh parking fines
whether it's with speeding fires
ministers of both parties over the years
but we've also we've yeah we've had
prime ministers in the past have penalty
notices from what i can see and we've
also front bench ministers well i saw
there was a parking notice that tony
blair had once we've seen front bench
labour
no no no you make the fight
as well the prime minister the previous
prime minister having a parking fine is
in any way uh correlated to our prime
minister making kovid rules when the
country was in lockdown 120 odd thousand
people have died and you can make the
comparison between the two you're saying
to me i'm asking you
you asked me if somebody who sets the
laws and the rules can also be someone
who breaks thoughts that clearly has
happened with a number of ministers over
the years but tony blair didn't make
himself on parking well the government
is responsible for all the rules and
regulations so you could argue that
governments don't pass
some of the specific local fines on
parking but still with a parking fine
it's broken it's still a law of the
country are you completely comfortable
making the comparisons with parking
fines
i'm just making the point that i'm just
asking if you are okay
yeah absolutely in the sense that
ministers in the past have sadly been
subject to getting fixed penalty notices
on a range of issues they can continue
to be ministers they do continue to be
ministers i've seen that in both
governments of the previous labour
government as well as the conservative
government the focus has to be on
accepting when you've done something
wrong and lodging that you've done that
which the prime minister has and being
focused on moving forward to do things
in the right way and what he has been
focused on and we have to say all
through kovid through this issue with
russia's invasion of ukraine the work
we're doing on the cost of living at the
moment is making life difficult with so
many people across the country we've got
a prime minister who's focused on
delivering on those things in a way that
works for people in this country and
that's why he's had my support will
continue to but that's right you know
that's why people think he's a liar
because he says i didn't break the rules
twice he misled parliament some might
say and yet um he still doesn't accept
that he broke the rules well that's not
the case first of all he hasn't misled
parliament he has outlines upon what he
believes to be the case and the truth at
the point he's equally quite rightly
apologize for what has happened accepted
the position the police have taken and
paid the fine and he is very much folks
even on that day if you look at his dive
today i'm focused on the issues that are
affecting people across the country on a
range of things as i say across cost of
living issues with the war in ukraine
issues as we're moving out and we're
moving out of covid and getting our
country moving forward in the way that
as men we're having the success
economically that we're having compared
to other countries if there are any more
fines will they be made public the
promise has always been very clear that
he'll be very open about uh any files
that he he was there anymore we will
hear it so no reason why anything would
change he's always been said he might be
very clear and open about that first and
he'll be able to actually said that to
me so thank you for the clarification
and i just wanted to clarify as far as
the ministerial code is concerned
because you said he didn't break the
rules uh it features a forward by the
prime minister himself and it says
ministers who knowingly misled
parliament will be expected to offer
their resignation to the prime minister
you're saying that he didn't knowingly
mislead them because on the 1st and 8th
of december when he said what he said he
didn't realize that when he was in the
cabinet room and potentially other
places and there was cake and goodness
knows what else he didn't realize that
was breaking the rules at the time no
exactly what's happened for him to now
realize what he still didn't think he'd
broken the rules until the police told
him well as i said his viewer when he
when he outlined that department was
that he was saying make making a
statement of facts what he believed to
be true that is absolutely the right
thing to do that's what you do in
parliament
and what he has done since then as we
saw last week with the fine from the
police he's accepting the police have
come to view um he has paid that fine he
has apologized um and he's making
changes in number 10 as he said he would
to reflect the changes he'd broken the
law well as you said when the police
have issued a fine the prime minister's
acceptance
before then you said that he was
clearing out before then
he accepted before then as we've said
and i think i spoke to you on this
program about this uh who didn't accept
before the people accepted that things
that happened at number 10 that people
didn't like sure the question is when
did he realize he had broken the law
when the police issued him a a fine he
is accepted why did he suck people
before then because
there's a difference between whether the
police decide if there is a fine to
issue because of what has been broken is
different to whether you realize and
take a view the things that happened at
number 10 and the way things were
happening number 10 was not right was
not appropriate he took action on that
a fair few weeks ago now a couple of
months ago now as he said he would and
apologized those issues he outlined upon
that his viewers that he hadn't broken
any rules that was the right thing to do
that was his belief at the time he is
also accepting the police have come to a
different view on this particular event
they've issued a fine he accepts that
he's acknowledged that he's paid the
fine and apologized and i'm going to
hear more from him i think about half
past three this afternoon yes later on
this afternoon lovely it's great to talk
to you thanks so much for joining us
thank you well as we've been hearing mr
johnson is expected to update the
commons around about half past three
this afternoon as parliament resumes
after the easter break we'll have uh
full coverage here on sky news and um on
wednesday actually of this week i'm
going to be chatting to the us
ambassadors to the uk for now that's
philip rica for a u.s perspective on the
war in ukraine and other pertinent
questions of the day that's at half past
eight on wednesday morning
nowhere is safe the harrowing headline
in the eye which reports on what it
calls a major escalation of the russian
offensive in ukraine
according to the times the ukrainian
president
uh that's vladimir lenski of course
believes this means that the next phase
of the war has begun
the mirror looks ahead to boris
johnson's appearance in parliament today
where he'll face questions over his
party gate fine
the metro hears that a million
discounted train tickets are to go on
sale in an effort to encourage rail
service and rail travel
the sun leads with the death of the
newborn son of the footballer cristiano
ronaldo and his partner
still to come on the programme for you
this morning later in the hour speaking
to the former british ambassador to
russia's attorney brenton about the
russian advance in ukraine
just after eight o'clock we'll get the
view from labour speaking to the shadow
attorney general emily thornbury and
putting to her one of the questions that
the minister suggested i should
and we'll speak to the former defense
minister tobias elwood who has himself
called for boris johnson to step down
following his party gate fine
cristiano ronaldo and his partner have
announced that one of their newborn
twins has died the manchester united
footballer and his girlfriend georgina
rodriguez had announced in october of
2021 that they were expecting twins in
december
they revealed they were expecting a boy
and a girl
the couple shared a post on social media
yesterday saying it is with deepest
sadness
what a shame that we have to announce
that our baby boy has passed away it's
the greatest pain that any parent can
feel
only the birth of our baby girl gives us
the strength to live this moment with
some hope and happiness goes on to say
we kindly ask for privacy at this very
difficult time our baby boy you are our
angel we will always love you
tributes have been pouring in following
the announcement ronaldo's football club
that's manchester united of course
tweeted your pain is our pain sending
love and strength to you and your family
at this time
and teammate marcus rashford wrote on
twitter thoughts are with you and
georgina brother i'm so sorry and
replying to the post on instagram
jamaican sprinter usain bolt sent his
condolences using a string of praying
hands emojis
more people have crossed the english
channel in small boats this weekend just
days after the government announced its
plan to send some asylum seekers who've
made the journey to rwanda
on sunday 76 people crossed the channel
in small boats
that takes the total number of people
who have made the journey so far this
year to more than four thousand
last year 28
526 people are known to have arrived in
the uk via small boats
let's get more on that should we muddy
standing by and over again for us this
morning hi maddie we saw more boats
arriving just yesterday the good weather
making migrants feel that they can risk
that crossing
good morning kay yes it was a glorious
sunny bank holiday and as we know now
that encourages more people to to take
the risks across the channel in these
comparatively favorable uh conditions of
course even in the sunniest flattest
karma sea uh and you know comparatively
good weather if you're on a proper boat
a yacht or um a ferry in a tiny dinghy
in the middle of the english channel
it's still incredibly dangerous
and lots and lots of people we know
sadly do lose their lives even in the
best weather when they're crossing so it
is dangerous but the good weather more
people attempt it and um we we know from
those latest figures from the ministry
defense 76 people crossed but they said
they just found just two boats so that
gives you a sense of how overcrowded how
dangerous they are two small boats with
76 people on
but even as people were arriving over
the weekend there was the most almighty
row unfolding over this um the
government's policy decision to send
people to rwanda for processing and
their asylum claims it started when the
archbishop of canterbury uh justin welby
criticized the government for
outsourcing and for subcontracting uh
their asylum policy saying in his view
it was opposite to what the nature of
god would have wanted then he was
supported by his predecessor the former
archbishop of canterbury uh dr rowan
williams who when asked about it said
yes he thought the policy was sinful and
since then it's not just the clergy
we've had plenty of tory grandes and and
uh um former ministers and members of
cabinet criticizing the government's
policy as well most recently uh or today
even uh david davis who was writing the
times that he thought this was not what
our hard-fought brexit freedoms were
about but undoubtedly there'll be more
back and forth over this today okay
maddie for now thanks so much indeed
let's look at some of today's other
headlines for you now should we and more
than a million tickets are being sold
off at up to half price in an attempt to
boost domestic tourism
it means the price of a rail journey
from london to edinburgh could come down
to 22 pounds but the discounts are only
on certain off-peak services during
april and may
labour said it would come as little
comfort following years of soaring fares
but those we've spoken to broadly
welcome the promotion
i think anything to like
encourage people to not drive
especially when they don't need to is a
good thing it's on average 67 pound 50
for me to get to work
for a return ticket so 300 pound a week
some people don't have the opportunity
to go away because it's so expensive or
do nice things because it's so expensive
so it just makes it a bit more open to
other people to to more people than it
probably is now
tell you about five-time olympic girl
medalist the bradley wiggins he's
revealed he was sexually groomed by a
cycling coach when he was just 13 years
old the tour de france winner said he
did not feel he could speak up at the
time due to a difficult relationship
with his stepfather
the boxer amir khan says he was robbed
at gunpoint in east london he tweeted
that he had been confronted by two men
who pointed a gun in his face he says he
was with his wife at the time he says no
one was physically hurt
my company announces at this moment if
you choose to you may remove your mask
travelers in the united states will no
longer have to wear masks on planes and
trains after a federal judge in florida
ruled it was unlawful
the change has been welcomed by the u.s
travel industry
sri lanka has made a request for rapid
financial assistance from the
international monetary fund to mitigate
its worst economic crisis in decades
anti-government protesters have been
talking to the sri lankan streets as the
country edges towards bankruptcy
johnny depp is expected to give evidence
today in the libel cases between him and
amber heard it comes after the court was
shown a series of pictures of the actor
with apparent lacerations and scratches
allegedly been caused by his former wife
hood's team said the actor injured his
own hand when smashing a phone against
the wall here's david blevins
johnny depp appeared slightly more
relaxed as the libel trial resumed for a
second week he and his ex-wife amber
heard who are suing each other over an
article she wrote about domestic
violence both returned to the virginia
courtroom depp's personal doctor read a
long list of disorders he's been
treating the actor for
primary dopamine imbalance adhd which is
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
bipolar one
depression secondary to above insomnia
chronic substance abuse disorder
he described finding depth with the tip
of his fingers sliced off following a
ride between the couple in australia how
long did you attend mr death outside of
the house
not long probably
a half hour i needed to get him to the
emergency room
i went in to instruct
one of the
people with him
to look for the tip of the finger
hoping that we would be able to put it
back
was the tip of the finger found
it was found
who found it
i believe this man was their chef
and do you know where he found it or
where he told you he found it
he said he found it in the kitchen area
the doctor said he'd never witnessed
johnny depp physically abuse amber heard
and he'd never treated her for any
injury depp who's expected to give
evidence today is suing his ex-wife for
50 million dollars alleging she defamed
him in the article she's countersuing
him for 100 million dollars alleging he
defamed her by describing her claims as
fake
david blevins sky news washington
should we take you to italy now why not
uh where greenpeace activists have
written the message on the side of a
russian crude oil tanker at sea here we
go
use yellow paint they wrote peace not
oil in large yellow letters on the side
of the tanker urging european
governments to stop using fossil fuels
they had sailed out to the tanker in a
rubber dinghy off the coast of sikarus
in sicily
what's happening as far as the weather
is concerned let's find out
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
next few days will be cooler and fresher
than recently with a scattering of
showers
mainly dry and quite chilly with the
grand frost in parts of the north and
the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
back to florida now where residents in
venice had a surprise early morning
visitor
here he is oh look at the size of him an
alligator was spotted sauntering along a
residential street at harrington lake
looking for water it looks like it may
have misjudged
just how long the walk was you can see
it's taking tiny little breaks no one's
gonna stopping
and uh resting gonna rest on someone's
driveway
yeah just having a minute however as you
can see he did
finally find his way back to water the
thing with
crocs and alligators is that you think
they move quite slowly
if they think that your food watch how
quick they move then
yeah
trust me he goes in now
tot
to trot pictured in the telegraph we
have a picture of
oh that made gorgeous i saw them this
morning bonnie and uh truly uh edwards
rather dashingly dressed taking part in
the london harness horse parade in west
sussex it's been an easter monday
tradition for 135
years i'm guessing their parents were
very proud indeed
at times shows us a rather challenging
job a group of beekeepers in somerset
dressed in full ppe while holding
smokers in case the bees get a little
bit agitated um
yeah they've probably still got the odd
sting though didn't they
wouldn't be for me
and the ultimate cat fight quite
literally the sun displays a picture of
a female tiger attacking her mate in
india allegedly because he wasn't in the
mood um
i think that people who write those sort
of headlines don't really understand
what cats are doing because female cats
are never in the mood they just do it to
procreate and he was probably
being very interested um nah just my
guess coming up i'm going to get
reaction to the latest development in
ukraine with the former british
ambassador to russia sir tony brenson
that's come
[Music]
hello again um everybody lots to talk
about today obviously we'll be
discussing the latest situation in
ukraine do you stay with us here on the
breakfast show here on sky tuesday
morning before that though party gate
yes it's rearing its head again today
ali is here why ali good morning really
big week for the prime minister because
obviously all of this happened in recess
which i think often sort of stilts
momentum a bit you don't have
politicians able to talk to people plot
face to face but now mp's are back and
the prime minister has said he will
address the commons set the record
straight today it's going to be a really
important week you were speaking to
brandon lewis this morning i thought he
was really interesting because he kept
saying he accepted the police's decision
that they had looked into this but i
felt like he was really stopping short
of saying that he accepted that the
prime minister had broken the rules and
i think that would be difficult ground
um for the prime minister to tread
what was really interesting sorry to
interrupt that because
it was interesting that he was making
the comparisons with parking fines from
tony blair and breaking the covid rules
uh laws that he'd made himself should we
just have a quick listen to what he said
here we go
we've had prime ministers in the past
have penalty notices from what i can see
and we've also had from bench ministers
well i saw there was a parking notice
that tony blair had once we've seen
front bench labour
no no no you make the problem
as well the prime minister the previous
prime minister having a parking fine is
in any way uh correlated to our prime
minister making kovid rules when the
country was in lockdown 120 odd thousand
people have died and you can make the
comparison between the two you're saying
to me i'm asking
you ask me if somebody who sets the laws
and the rules can also be someone who
breaks thoughts that clearly has
happened with a number of ministers over
the years but tony blair didn't make the
rules on parking well the government is
responsible for all of the rules and
regulations so you could argue that
governments don't pass um this some of
the specific local fines on parking but
still with the parking fine it's broken
it's still a law of the country are you
completely comfortable making the
comparisons with parking fines
i'm just making the point that i'm just
asking if you are
yeah absolutely in the sense that
ministers in the past have sadly been
subject to getting fixed penalty notices
on a range of issues
pretty um
interesting to say the least comparison
i think he's making between
parking fines which are usually civil
and fixed penalty notices which if
they're not paid this is what the prime
minister got could end up with criminal
well we know he got criminal sanctions
but if they're not paid there could be
criminal conviction even so it's it's an
unusual comparison to be making i think
you know the big question now
perhaps the most important question this
week is the prime minister going to get
any more fines because we've seen seven
mps now publicly calling for him to go
immediately
double that around her publicly
questioning his position but what you
get is a sort of drip drip now
particularly the mps are back and if we
get even more indications that he has
broken the rules i think this will
become increasingly hard to defend and
we could see things changing really
quickly okay ali for now thanks very
much indeed thanks a lot
uh meantime i also actually and we'll
see you at nine o'clock of course won't
we for alice take thank you uh meanwhile
i also asked the minister this morning
the northern ireland secretary about two
british fighters that have been taken
hostage in ukraine
by russian forces what should happen
with them now
russia's saying is if you give us victor
medvedek then you can have these two
brits back is that something that we
would get involved with that sort of
negotiation this is an oligarch who um
as we know was an opposition leader in
ukraine for a while mp there i think at
the moment well we're actually going
through the process of sanctioning um
people who are close to putin regime
we're not going to be um looking at how
we can help russia we're looking to
actually ensure that the pewter regime
is unsuccessful in this apollo invasion
and we'll continue to do everything we
can to support the ukrainian people
ukrainian president and government to
defeat beauty i understand so these guys
are on their own they're really for now
well they shouldn't have been there it's
an illegal act to be there obviously
anybody will have sympathy with somebody
who has been taken hostage but we have
got to make sure that we follow the
proper processes that we are dealing
with this in the right way we give the
support in the right way that the
ukrainian armed forces and the ukrainian
government ukrainian people can make
good use of
let's bring in deborah should we she's
standing by for us in kiev this morning
deborah i'm not sure if you heard much
of the interview with the minister
obviously you're in a war zone this
morning but um it does look as though
those two guys are on their own
yes well he was making clear wasn't he
that they the british government isn't
approving of any british citizen wanting
to come here and join the fight but
there are a number of volunteers on the
ground that have been
motivated by ukraine's fight for
survival against russia's invasion the
the russian foreign ministry has
actually said that or claimed there to
be hundreds of uh foreign fighters in
the besieged city of mariopol which is
one of the key focuses at the moment of
the war it's a city that russia has been
trying to take from the very beginning
on the southeast uh port uh of the sea
of azov and there is this core of
fighters ukrainian fighters largely that
have been holding out they were given a
window to surrender to lay down their
arms on sunday they refuse to do that
and are still holding out and it is all
part of this wider offensive that
ukraine's president declared had begun
in the donbass region a second phase of
the war almost two months in and a phase
that both sides need to win it could
become it could be a decisive moment
russia failed to take the capital keefe
it then has had a rethink it's obviously
learned from its mistakes and setbacks
and is now focusing its superior
firepower
on the east which means a huge test for
the ukrainian military which has managed
to withstand against the odds the
russian offensive so far but will need
all the support it can get from its
western allies in terms of weapons if
it's going to be able to hold out again
in the east which is so vital if it's
going to continue to push
russia back and thwart vladimir putin's
attempt to topple the government here in
kiev
okay for now thank you very much thanks
a lot deborah
i mean let's speak to the former british
ambassador to russia should we uh sir
tony branson hello to you so tony it's
good to see you again thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
um first of all should we just start
with the latest situation uh in the
donbass region it does look as though i
mean
initially when the war first broke out
we thought this was the region that
russia would be most interested in they
had a scatter gun approach but now
consolidating in that area how surprised
are you
no i'm not surprised this has been
pretty clearly coming for a few weeks as
the russians have been after failing in
their initial assaults on kiev have been
reorganizing to go precisely for the
donbass the donbass is the logical place
for them to go for one of the claims
they've made in launching the war was to
protect the population of the donbass
from what they described as ukrainian
genocide
i'm sorry
that's okay as long as it's not
president putin we can wait no no no
okay i've killed it um
so this was predictable it is now
launched and
it is as your correspondent deborah i
think said probably we're not the
decisive phase of the war because one of
two things can happen
either they succeed in in the donbass
and take that region in which case
they've got a huge negotiating
ploy
they've got a huge negotiating ploy to
use with the um the ukrainians in any in
any discussions that might then take
place or there is a danger that putin
may revive his earlier ambition of going
again for kiev and going for the whole
of ukraine in effect
the alternative and i suspect more
likely um of course is that this thing
is going to get bogged down as their
previous offensive gets bogged down
you're in for a quite long war of
attrition between the two sides at which
point both sides at some point will
begin looking for a negotiated outcome
but we'll have to see a lot now depends
immensely on how the military campaign
goes yeah has it not been proven um or
have we not seen that um ukraine
ukrainian fighters um are more than what
uh president putin was expecting they
have suffered heavy defeats both with
their armory and indeed with their
military personnel as well and trying to
take over the whole of ukraine is not
feasible
well it was not feasible not on their
original
approach which was to send their troops
in every every possible direction
whether it is feasible to take the
donbass and then proceed from there
remains to be seen
as i say i think the likelihood is not
and yes we all got it wrong initially
the chief of the us general staff said
at the very beginning that the russians
were likely to be able to take care of
in 72 hours so lots of military experts
have got egg on their face about the
incapacity of the russians to win the
war as they initially fought it the big
question is whether they've they've
resolved the incompetence that they
showed the first time around they found
themselves as you said up against a much
more effective and cohesive and high
morale ukrainian armed force than they
expected and also a ukrainian armed
force which has been massively armed and
the uk has a lot to do with this by the
west which has made a very big
difference to their ability to uh to
advance
talk to me about i mean we said that you
were um the ambassador to russia uh in i
think 2004 to 2008 i think that's right
insane mr ambassador i'm sure you must
have met putin in that time um what sort
of man
how do you remember him and how do you
think he'll be dealing with what's
happening in ukraine at the moment well
how i remember him is this is a very
able focused
not very nice
um
leader of russia driven by the desire to
make russia great against coin of phrase
and a man who took risks but calculated
rather carefully before taking them
very clearly the the putin we're dealing
with now is in some significant ways
different that he has launched this he's
taken this huge risk of this war
i think
he's been brooding over his isolation
swimming covered about ukraine which he
sees as central to making russia great
again has launched this war which it
looks very unlikely that he could win he
can win on the terms that he originally
set for himself so he's disappointed i
suspect he's angry
he's talked a couple of times about
going nuclear which would be a very big
threshold to cross if he went for it
but i wouldn't rule it out entirely if
things go very badly wrong for him so i
suspect that what we need to be doing is
persuading if not him personally than
the people around him that there is a a
respectable way out of this
for russia
and which preserves ukraine and we need
to be edging our way towards that so
does the west have to give him from what
you're saying some sort of get out of
get out clause
so that he won't use potentially nuclear
weapons is that what you're saying let
me give you a little bit of history back
in 1962
president john f kennedy dealing with
the cuban missile crisis said that what
the united states absolutely must not do
is confront a nuclear-armed
adversary by which he meant the soviet
union at the time with the choice
between total humiliation and nuclear
escalation
that remains as true today as it was
when he said it yes the russians have
behaved appallingly yes the political um
feel of dealing with a country which has
committed so many atrocities and so many
illegalities is going to be very hard
but if the alternative is to move across
the nuclear threshold then we're going
to have to bite our tongues a bit and do
it
in the meantime what about these two
british fighters as far as the british
government is concerned via the northern
ireland secretary this morning you know
they're they're there illegally um and
it does sound as though they're on their
own for now russia wants to do a deal a
prisoner swap deal if you will with a
with a ukrainian
uh mp former leader of the opposition in
ukraine um what do you think putin will
do about these two
i think he probably sees them as
negotiating material for use with us um
we in putin's eyes are among the most um
rabid of the west's opponents to russia
um they are useful for
discussions as part of what eventually
we all hope will be a peace negotiation
what we
there are some things we obviously need
to be doing we need to be seeking
consular access to them to make sure
that they're being treated decently we
need to make it sure we need to make it
clear to putin that indeed their fate
will form part of whatever negotiation
we eventually end up in and if they are
maltreated then that will form part of
our attitude in those negotiations but
in terms of getting them out quickly
barring a a real change of mood on the
part of the russians i don't think that
that's very likely to happen
okay so tony um fascinating stuff uh
i'll let you get back to your phone call
thank you very much indeed for joining
us much appreciated not at all thank you
for joining us right bye-bye bye-bye
thank you
now footage has been released of
soldiers and civilians many of which are
children hold up in a steelworks in the
port city of mariopol as the fighting
continues around them ukrainian
officials say russia is dropping more
bombs as it looks to fully capture mario
paul after a six-week assault mark stone
reports a warning his report does
contain distressing images
including a body
released late last night this video it
is claimed shows the last remaining
civilians in mariupol
they're in a makeshift bomb shelter at
the steel works in this key port city
the video was filmed and released by the
ukrainian military's azov battalion
it is their soldiers who have been
holding out for weeks against the
russian forces here and they are now
cornered in the steel works
we can't yet independently verify when
it was filmed or precisely where but as
of commanders are using it as an appeal
i am the commander of the azov regiment
he says and i call on the leaders of the
world right now mariupol at the steel
factory hundreds of civilians are
sheltering
they found their only available shelter
was next to ukrainian soldiers who are
still defending the city from russian
invaders
i urge the politicians of the civilized
world to organize a proper green
corridor to ensure safety and provide
immediate evacuation for everyone
this drone footage was released
yesterday by the same ukrainian unit it
shows their soldiers still capable of an
attack against their russian enemy we've
located it to the city but we can't
verify when it was filmed
and to the northwest in nepro at the
military cemetery the daily burials
the families farewell
a units farewell
just two weeks ago there was just one
row of graves here this is one cemetery
in one city in one region
andre breslatev was 25.
it's the scale of the loss
and the waste it really hits you here
and the tragedy is that there is no sign
at all of anything changing
quite the opposite
the breadth of the monday russian
barrage has been remarkable this is
kharkiv 250 miles north of mariupol 700
miles east of the attacks in lev
ukraine's second city still being
bombarded still resisting occupation
but here's the cost
the victim
is her father
in eastern ukraine
president vladimir zelinsky says russian
forces have begun a new offensive in the
donbass region of ukraine local media
reporting a series of explosions have
been heard with air sirens
going off during the night joining us is
former ukrainian ambassador to the eu
constantine
yezidlev
it's good to see you thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the programme
forgive me for the pronunciation of your
surname sir um
what's your understanding of what is
happening uh to the east
of your country
first of all uh as you know uh russian
troops unleashed uh heavy and massive
artillery and
missile
and rocket fire all along the
eastern
flank of ukraine and this is
i would call the second stage of russian
full-fledged war against ukraine and you
just showed the picture of marijuana
which has become a symbol of ukraine's
struggle
against the russian war and once again
this is a full-fledged bloody war
unleashed by putin's regime and uh on
the example of mariupol putin clearly
shows what he wants
to do with ukraine tomorrow that's why
this is a warning signal an alarm to the
entire democratic world to act
not just to talk the talks but to do
something more
clear to
show the bravery and finally to help to
ukrainian people to win in this bloody
war because uh
we we need your help
in order to save you because we are
struggling and we are fighting not only
for ukraine we are struggling for the
entire democratic world
do you get the impression that russia is
consolidating now to the east of the
country or do you think they're
regrouping and there is cause for
concern for the rest of the country
again we know that people had started to
return to la viv haven't they but there
have been at least seven explosions
overnight
look uh on the example of rio which is a
western part of ukraine this is a clear
example that there is no safe place in
ukraine now but for you i would like to
explain that putin does not
do not need neither mario
[Music]
he would like to have in its own pocket
the whole ukraine his aim just to if not
to conquer ukraine um at least to erase
ukraine from the uh map
of the or from the international map so
that's why now we are fighting for our
existence for our independence
the
tragedy of the situation that ukrainians
we would like to
be to survive we would like to to to
live in peace and democracy and
at the same time putin would like to see
all us bad so i would like just to call
upon to the entire world please
understand us clearly currently under
your eyes
there is a real tragedy so please help
us and please
act more decisively not to wait not to
think and in this regard i count very
much on the leadership of
great britain and the united states in
order to mobilize the massive support in
terms of defensive and offensive weapons
to ukraine
okay um we appreciate you taking the
time to join us this morning sir do keep
safe thank you for joining us
thank you
now let me just uh show you this story
in today's times that is a reminder why
stealing is never a smart idea
a man in ukraine has been able to track
the location of the russian soldier who
stole his airpod apple headphones from
his home in kiev by using the find my
feature
the man posted updates at the airport's
journey on social media he was able to
track the redeployment of soldiers to
the russian city of belgarrod where
troops are amassing for an assault on
the donbass region of ukraine how clever
was that and how stupid not to switch
off the find my phone feature if you've
already stolen some of these things uh
there you go so you never thought that
it would be that useful i'm sure he's
not going to be asking for them back
though
and a government minister has defended
the prime minister's coveted fine to
receiving a parking ticket we'll get the
view of labour's shadow attorney general
in just a few moments time so we heard
from the northern ireland secretary he
said that breaking the covert rules that
the prime minister had made for which he
got a fine can be comparable with a
parking fine that the previous prime
minister tony blair received when he was
prime minister
you decide see in a second
[Music]
you